for those forced to breathe in toxic air
every day it can seem that little is
being done to address this issue so
let's talk about a little bit more uh
david wallis wells this is something
that you've written extensively about so
are we taking pollution seriously enough
do you think
the short answer is absolutely not it
seems to me to be among the biggest
public health and environmental crises
of our time
in some ways a bigger problem even than
climate change the mortality
statistics are overwhelming most data
suggests at least 7 million people
perhaps as many as 10 or more million
people a year dying from air pollution
most of that from the burning of fossil
fuels that is an unfathomable
amount of death and much more suffering
besides i think we're not doing nearly
enough in part because many of um many
of us living in places like uk and the
us don't regard the humanity of people
living in places like india
adequately but also because we regard
the status quo in which we ourselves in
our relatively clean air suffering as
acceptable simply because it is the
status quo and don't think about what
kind of a better cleaner healthier
future we could be building and then
also a more prosperous one if we took
the opportunity to more rapidly
transition off of those deadly fuels and
into a much greener cleaner future and
dave i can see you nodding there and i
think you've got some personal
experience you feel that you've been
affected by pollution don't you
oh yes i have i have grown up in an area
of where most kids in primary schools
have asthma and i grew up thinking that
was totally normal which it isn't
i'm living in an area where we have an
incinerator and we watch the incinerator
burn over a community that's mostly
populated by black and brown people of
working-class backgrounds this is the
reality of air pollution it's not just
something that affects our health but it
affects our developmental stages it
affects communities as a whole and the
fact that it's allowed to be continued
for so long is disgusting
in places like for example in lewisham
in london it's six times over the legal
levels of air pollution it's literally
illegal to breathe the air that we're
breathing currently and we are not even
the worst when is it going to be enough
when are enough people going to die for
governments to care
well yes and that's interesting isn't it
you quoted that figure from the world
health organization david saying that
around 7 million people die from air
pollution annually but as days pointed
out it's not just in in some of those
poorer developing countries it is also
in big wealthy cities as well so do you
think that people are waking up to this
they're beginning to
i think they're beginning to a lot of
the scariest research is now just a few
years old and it tends to take a little
while for that kind of stuff to sort of
circulate and percolate and and begin to
change public opinion and public policy
i think the more we talk about it the
more we note it um the more alarmed
we'll be and i do think the research is
going to continue moving very much in
this direction the world health
organization just a couple months ago
changed its threshold the standard that
it says is safe they cut it in half
which means it used to be the case that
90 percent of the world was living in
places with dangerously polluted air now
it's something closer to 90 and 90 which
means almost nobody is safe and in fact
the researchers doing that work say
possibly even that safe threshold isn't
safe they just haven't really done the
work yet on the lower levels of air
pollution to know but they suspect that
as it was with lead pollution
no level of air pollution will be safe
at all and we'll still be seeing um
death from pollution but also
as days was pointing out developmental
problems um cognitive problems
behavioral problems produced in part at
least from this pollution which is an
elective
problem we could be burning much less
fossil fuel we could be
burning much less farmland these are
choices we make in part through policy
um which are killing at least seven and
you know the figures i trust are more
like 10 million people a year which is
again just an absolutely staggering
figure it means 100 million deaths a
decade it means 400 million deaths in my
lifetime that is
the kind of thing that we should be
orienting an entire moral politics
around not one that we should be
treating as an environmental
afterthought
you